roy benitez
leader of the jtf has been on the front
line since the dollar flu was first
unleashed on new york city
he is respected by those around him
particularly by those under his command
and the division agents working
alongside him
he is legitimately a good man who only
hopes to be able to do his part in
helping the city
make it through this chaotic time so
what could he have possibly done to
assist in the creation
of the rogue agent network
[Music]
[Music]
roy benitez was a narcotics officer for
eight years
before being promoted to precinct
captain his father was a chinatown
police officer
who referred to police work as the
family business so for benitez
it only felt natural to follow in his
father's footsteps and join the force
he received multiple accolades for his
bravery over his career
and was among the first of the
responders to the 9 11 tragedy
and barely managed to escape the
collapse of the south tower
he endeavors to always do the right
thing even if that means upsetting a few
people along the way
for him there are only two ways of doing
things the right way
and the wrong way benitez is a
well-documented love for new york city
not just the area but the people too he
is a proud new yorker
before the dollar flu outbreak benitez
and his wife were on the verge of
separation
his religious commitment to the police
force coupled with their inability to
have children
placed immense strain on their
relationship and when the illness
claimed her life
benitez took her loss extremely hard and
it triggered guilt that he still
struggles to deal with
to this day
benitez was put in the position of
leading the joint task force in new york
city
signed on for a thankless job in a
thankless time
but i just wanted to say thank you
the work we are doing here is ceaseless
and
painful and necessary
we're all tired and hungry
bruised and broken but we
pick ourselves up
drink some water dream of kermans
and get ready for another day i just
want you to know
that even if we don't talk if we never
see each other in person and only check
in
over the radio every single one of you
is important every single one of you is
needed
every single one of you brings something
to the table
that makes us better and stronger
i trust you with my life
and i hope that you trust me
he is well respected by those under his
command and they trust him to make the
right decisions with their lives
and the future of new york city in mind
however some of these decisions are not
his to make
following the construction of the
quarantine zone in the middle of
manhattan
benitez tasked the jtf with running the
security
this quickly proved to be too big of a
job as the area was simply too large to
be managed effectively
eventually the riots began to get out of
control
gangs and hostile groups started to
merge together
and over time overthrow a number of the
regions within the city
jtf officers were being pushed back
attacked
and murdered it became a conflict zone
and no man's land
eventually news of this made it back to
the white house and president waller
activated director 51 dispatching the
strategic homeland division to new york
city
the majority of the shd were given the
job of assisting the jtf
with regaining control of the quarantine
zone
but even with the addition of these
highly trained individuals it was too
late
the small team of division agents had
proved ineffective at getting control of
the situation
so the president requested the
activation of a second wave of division
agents
to bolster numbers however not long
after
the president and then the vice
president died under mysterious
circumstances
and the speaker of the house was sworn
in
president ellis immediately ordered a
full retreat of all jtf personnel from
the midtown manhattan quarantine zone
on top of this he wanted the entrances
sealed off effectively walling anyone
who remained
inside and it was benitez's job to make
sure this happened
ordered the jtf out of the zone and he
had them block off all entrances
ensuring that no one could get in or out
thousands of civilians construction
workers in the first way the division
agents were trapped inside
most of which would never be heard from
a game
shortly after the second wave of the
division agents arrived on the scene
though the majority of them were killed
while in transit a handful were able to
make their way through to the base of
operations in manhattan
meanwhile at the jtf's lincoln tunnel
checkpoint benitez's location was
overrun by rioters
luckily for him the second wave division
agents had managed to make it to him in
time
rescuing and returning him to the base
of operations
although initially he wasn't overly
happy about having to work with the feds
over time he began to warm to the agents
with the division agents taking point
and benitez commanding the jtf in
support
they were able to work together to
direct missions against the multiple
hostile factions who were taking control
of the city
the rioters cleaners lmb and rikers
throughout the city have been severely
crippled in their attempts to take
control
their leaders have been eliminated and
even the power vacuum that closely
followed
has been put to rest but the fight
wasn't over
[Music]
benitez's close colleague throughout the
crisis paul rhodes
has decided that enough is enough rhodes
always struggled with the calls coming
from above
and has disagreed with the way the
division agency operated from the start
given too much power a number of these
agents were starting to turn their backs
on the country
by going rogue which was in his opinion
creating more harm than good
so he wanted to get as far away from
feylau and the division as possible
benitez was the glue that was holding
them together up until now
but even he couldn't stop this valuable
member of the team from leaving
kowalski you're leaving too so cap
they made a pretty compelling argument
yeah they do
look you need me to stick around and
wrap things up
it's fine we'll cover for you i don't
want to put the others at risk
don't worry about it thanks you know
sorry for asking cap but never consider
leaving joining the peacekeepers i
thought about it
it's not for me the bed still matters
at least we need to pretend that it does
along with roads a number of jtf
personnel started to depart
and joined the local civilian settlement
called haven
this dropping personnel number meant
that the jtf barely had enough manpower
and patrols to maintain order or to
defend vital positions
settlements and other locations like the
base of operations city hall
and lower manhattan we live severely on
demand and vulnerable to attack
i'm doing everything that i can we need
six man patrols on six hour shifts
you're telling me we don't have 24 guys
to keep us safe
i'm telling you i don't have 24 machines
that can keep up that schedule
we need at least 60 guards to fill these
shifts you know we don't have that many
then you don't get to have six-man
patrols around the clock this won't hold
roy
we're gonna get overrun but if we push
him too hard without rest they're gonna
make mistakes and we'll lose them
but i can get you two the rest will have
to rely on automated defenses and strike
teams
we can't keep cutting corners like this
we have to budget our resources
you keep budgeting like this there won't
be any corners left to cut
with jtf numbers continuing to resign
and join up with the civilian
peacekeepers
face concerns eventually became reality
captain i heard any news on the scale of
the attack
there's nothing left a handful of
survivors made it out and are with the
medics right now
jesus any patrols in the area turner and
her squad are ready but won't move until
they have backup
two more squads are on their way as we
speak and faye she's gone
her sister wasn't among the survivors
i'll turn her to keep an eye out
if they reaches the site she'll need all
the support she can get
yes sir the settlement in hell's kitchen
district
was attacked by ruckers with near to no
defensive systems
and a dwindling amount of jtf to
properly guard and patrol the facilities
there were massive casualties including
faith sister
she put seoul blame directly onto the
jtf and the fact that they didn't have
the numbers to protect the people
entrusted into their care
but this wasn't the only area that was
hit there was an attack on city hall
division agents from dc were called in
to investigate
they learned that the attack was
orchestrated by the rogue first wave
agent
aaron kina city hall was the jtf and
division's main foothold in lower
manhattan
serving as the base of operations for
the area
but with the building destroyed and the
remnants of the eclipse virus found all
over the compound
benitez fey and the division agents into
the civilian settlement
haven keener and his group of rogue
agents
are known to be located in lower
manhattan so they had to set up a
forward operating base in the area
with benitez's help paul rhoads
reluctantly allows the division to use
haven as a temporary base of operations
but over the coming months more and more
agents are showing themselves as rogues
as well as the once second wave
commanding officer feylau
so that was a very quick summary of the
story and benitez's involvement in it so
far
basically under orders benitez and the
jtf
set up the dark zone the president
activated the first wave of division
agents to assist the jtf with
maintaining control
in quick succession the president and
the vice president died
leaving the speaker of the house as the
new president
the new president immediately ordered
the withdrawal of the jtf from the dark
zone
leaving the division agents to fend for
themselves
this action resulted in the first wave
agents to go dark
either killed or abandoning the mission
this also led to the uprising of the
story's most influential antagonist
aaron kina who would go on to rally
other agents in his mission of
overthrowing the government
benitez is probably the last decent
person in power in new york
he is loyal good to the people under his
command and legitimately wants to help
society get through this
with no ulterior motive however always
the good little soldier
he will blindly follow commands without
question
my question is what would have happened
if benitez had ignored that one order
altogether the order that seems to have
started the whole kine-fueled
rogue agent movement he didn't even need
to completely ignore the command
if he had procrastinated long enough
president ellis would show his true
colours
and the general command structure of the
government would have shut down
completely anywhere
this one action has been responsible for
not just aaron kina but the large
majority of the first wave agents who
turned rogue
it always seems to come back to how the
government left them behind to die
now kina is obviously a special case
there is this possibility that he would
have always ended up going this way
anyway
this situation may have just escalated
his intentions
but without this particular event he
would have had a much harder time
convincing so many agents to follow his
cause
over time we've seen him manipulate so
many agents who are forced to abandon
their posts
based on this one particular instance
sure he may have managed to convince
a few especially the ones who were
directly affected by the jtf withdrawal
but his numbers an available skill set
that he would have tapped into
would have been considerably lower it
could have even stopped the deployment
of the hunters
depending on which theory you follow
however this would have had little to no
effect on the sudden addition
of the black tusk as we know they've
been looking in the shadows since before
the first wave was even activated
though it would have meant that the
division numbers would have been
substantially higher when combating
their advances
look at what a handful of agents have
managed to achieve imagine if there were
10
20 or 30 times those numbers
now obviously benitez could have simply
been replaced if he had failed to follow
orders
but given the state of how things were
and how quickly things went downhill
this would have been unlikely i mean who
would have replaced him
plus these men and women in the jtf have
seen some pretty horrible things by this
stage
chain of command would obviously be
important to these people but for a lot
of them this command seems to have been
lost
and is out of touch they will have been
focusing on those closest to them
and for someone they respect as much as
benitez even if he had told them exactly
what he was told to do
and that he was choosing not to do it a
decent portion would have continued to
follow him to the end
regardless look at what happened later
on
the president's siding with the black
tusk rogue division agents who had once
worked alongside them
loads of jtf lost faith in the
government and left their positions
because of what was happening above
around them they needed someone like
benitez
to take charge benitez was forced to
follow an order that he knew wasn't the
right thing to do
and he continues to regret it to this
day this call led to thousands of deaths
in the dark zone
and many more because of the following
rogue movement that developed later on
however i'm someone who was told from an
early age that i have problems with
authority
and questioned far too much i'd be a
terrible fit for any military
or police unit so what do you think
do you think you could have followed
through the command like this
don't get me wrong i think roy benitez
is the most decent and wholesome person
in the division story
i think he just made an error in
judgment not following his intuitions
a mistake that the country has been
paying for ever since
but of course we need to remember
hindsight is a beautiful thing
no one could have predicted that this
would have happened
another thing you need to consider is
this sounds very similar to the way
things played out for colonel ridgway
and the true sons
but benitez wasn't programmed this way
he wanted what was best for the people
of the city
however wasn't this what ridgeway wanted
to
what is right can be seen from many
different angles at a time like this
and unless you can read the future who
knows how some of these situations could
play out
how are you holding up right fine you
know it's a sin
to lie to a priest yes father sorry
some days are better than others and
today has been one of the bad ones
what's bothering you guilt i suppose
what do you have to feel guilty about
i just don't feel that i deserve to be
here when so many people have served
under me are not
how many do you think would be lost if
you weren't still here
i made mistakes father huge mistakes it
just made everything worse
you can't punish yourself for the past
all you can do is try to make amends in
the future
and every day you're doing that roy
every day you keep these people safe
every day you wake up and keep going
you are making amends for the sins you
inherited i just don't know that it'll
ever be enough
the jtf pulled back and the first wave
were crushed
because of it i should have fought
harder i shouldn't have let them do that
to those agents
a bit of an odd one this time but i hope
you enjoyed it and before the lynch mob
comes at me
i actually like benitez's character i
just wanted to take this video in a
slightly different direction than simply
talking about his past
i like analyzing the story and how
things could have ended up if things
have played out differently
like i've said in the past if at the
very least i can open you up to the
depth or the direction the story could
have taken
i've achieved what i aim to do
otherwise i am aware of a number of
story leaks that are out there at the
moment
i know far more than i would like to
know about the potential direction the
division story is going to take
i do not plan on covering any of this
one
none of this has been confirmed by the
divs and could be taken completely out
of context like we've seen in the past
and two i don't want to ruin the future
story it's already destroyed my ability
to speculate on these things
i'd rather not screw it up for others
anyway i'll catch in the next one cheers
agent my people say the threat has been
eliminated
i thank you my guys thank you and the
people of new york [ __ ] thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you